rinse the moral social and political
implications of capitalism through the
eyes of more than a dozen European
thinkers including adam smith friedrich
hayek and Karl Marx this talk from Yale
University is an hour and 10 minutes
you're our oral invited of course to
move up there she their seats up close
the sound system of course works and
there may be more people coming in
because I have a tendency to organize
these events loosely you know there's
wine before there's wine after and so
this is this is the second Henry cone
lecture that we have this semester we
were very fortunate that Henry cone is
here with us thank you for coming Henry
it's a lectureship that was set up a few
years ago to bring the campus figures
from virtually any field Henry himself I
believe was an economics major at Yale
University and so the topic this this
afternoon is of major consequence to mr.
Cohen who is here's had a chance to
speak with our speaker and who has read
the book what I want to do in order to
locate your speech service to introduce
to present to us the man who will do
that for us Professor Steven Smith
professor political science master of
Branford college thank you very much
rabbi Pinet and again let me also thank
the Cohen family for their generosity
and supporting this lecture series it's
a pleasure to be here today in this
sanctuary of learning and reflection and
thought particularly in contrast to
what's going on outside but in any case
it is a special pleasure to welcome to
Yale an old friend Jerry Muller who
among other things happens to be a Yale
parent
and that's a special cause for tribute
and celebration and also to celebrate
the publication of his new book the mind
in the market capitalism in modern
Europe professor Muller is a professor
of history catholic university of
america in washington DC like many of
the very best intellectual historians he
cut his teeth on german political theory
and german intellectual history with a
book on Hans fryer and the D
radicalisation of German conservatism it
was called more recently he's turned his
attention to questions of politics and
economics or maybe it's better to say
the politics of economics he is the
author of a book on Adam Smith he is the
editor of an anthology on conservative
thought from David Hume to the present
and again most recently his new book the
mind in the market capitalism in modern
Europe the talk today drawn from that
book is called moral political and
social ramifications of capitalism and
it is with a special pleasure that I'm
glad to welcome Jerry Muller to Yale and
to slifka Center Jerry
Thank You Stephen I the book that that
professor Smith mentioned the mind in
the market capitalism in modern modern
European thought was a book that i wrote
to deal with the ways in which modern
european intellectuals have thought
about capitalism about the way it works
of course but also about its moral
ramifications its cultural ramifications
and its political ramifications how they
thought about capitalism depended of
course in good part on their experience
and observations at a particular time
and place how they interpreted those
experiences dependent in part on their
larger interests their larger cultural
purposes and also on the inherited
frameworks of thought that they brought
to bear in thinking through those
contemporary experiences the main
purpose of the book was a kind of Arnold
Ian one that is to present the best that
has been thought and said in the world
at least in the modern European world on
the topic of capitalism and its
political and moral and cultural
ramifications in order as Arnold said to
to cast a fresh stream of thought upon
our stock notions but in the course of
writing that book one of the themes that
emerged and that indeed emerged more
strongly than I had originally
anticipated was the theme about the
links between capitalism and Jews indeed
as I say it turned out to be a more
significant theme then I had first
imagined when I began writing the book
and so today I want to focus on one of
the sub themes in the book and that is
the theme of anti-capitalism and
anti-semitism and by anti-capitalism I
mean an antipathy to capitalism as such
that is to say an antipathy to assist
them based upon the market as the major
means of economic coordination the price
mechanism private property and
competition by anti-capitalism I don't
mean this
satisfaction with one or another element
of the market and an attempt to reform
it that's something that even the most
Philo capitalist intellectuals indeed
the brightest Philo capitalist
intellectuals have been trying to do at
least since the time of Adam Smith to
analyze its dysfunctions and to try to
find ways of obviating them now I mean a
principled antipathy to the market as
such and similarly by anti-semitism I
mean an ideological antipathy to Jews or
to Judaism as such again that's not the
same as criticizing one or another
element of Judaism or one or another
element of the behavior of actual Jews
and I'm not going to argue that all
opponents of capitalism were
anti-semites that would be absurd nor am
i arguing that all anti-semites were
anti-capitalist they were not but I am
arguing that for several complex but
comprehensible reasons there was often a
linkage between hostility to the Jews
and hostility to the capitalist market
and today I want to focus on four
notions about four anti-capitalist
notions that were often linked to
anti-semitism one the notion that
commerce is fundamentally unproductive
secondly the suspicion of self-interest
otherwise known as greed thirdly the
notion of the evils of capitalist
innovation and forth the resentment of
success it's important to keep in mind
that ever since the Middle Ages Jews in
the Christian West we're associated with
the handling of money and so it's not
surprising then that an intellectual
evaluation of an economy in which money
played a central role was often
intertwined with attitudes towards the
Jews or towards Judaism and we have to
keep in mind the significance of the
notion of usury in Western thought in
general commerce was disdained by the
classical Greek authors by the Fathers
of the Church and to a lesser but still
significant degree by medieval Christian
field
bhajans but no element or no aspect of
Commerce what it was as reviled as the
lending of money for the sake of
interest and that that tendency to view
the taking of interest as something
morally evil and unproductive had both
biblical and Greek sources you may
recall that the 23rd chapter of the book
of Deuteronomy says quote you may lend
with interest to foreigners but to your
brother you may not lend with interest
unquote and that was interpreted by the
rabbi's as forbidding Jews from lending
with interest to one another but
allowing them to lend to non-jews
incidentally Jews eventually developed
legal fictions that allow them to lend
money to one another as well but that's
not part of today's story medieval
Christian theologians drew upon this
biblical verse but they interpreted it
through an Aristotelian lens Aristotle
maintained that money was in some sense
fundamentally unproductive and that it
was therefore unnatural and immoral to
earn interest for lending money the
condemnation of usury which was by the
way not lending money at high interest
it was lending money at interest per se
would come to occupy a central place in
the writings of Christian theologians up
through the early modern period they
took this practice which Aristotle had
considered blameworthy and regarded it
as sinful Thomas Aquinas cited Aristotle
to argue that money was sterile by
nature and the notion that quote money
does not beget money unquote became
central to scholastic economic doctrine
and there was also a kind of spillover
effect of this condemnation of usury
that's very important to understand and
that is to say to a great degree the
suspicion of usery was extended to
commerce as such that is to say all
commerce was seen as in danger of
overlapping with usury and in many ways
that makes a lot of sense after all
buying and selling a commodity
for the sake of making profit is not
that different from lending out money
for the sake of making profit I don't
mean that the considered doctrine of the
scholastics was that all commerce was
evil but all commerce was suspect and
the moral stigma of usury extended to
other types of commercial activity that
were seen as possibly injurious to the
community and so from from Aquinas
through the 18th century Catholic
casuistry maned vitally concerned with
distinctly this with distinguishing
profits which were user eous and hence
elicit from listen profits now in the
later Middle Ages the prohibition of
usury led to a clash between economic
realities and religious claims new
agricultural surpluses made possible a
more commercial economy and that made
the economic function of lending money
more important than it had ever been the
church struggled against usury by
Christians but money lending was more
necessary for the economy than it had
been in the past and so a mortal sin of
theology became immortal necessity of
commercial life as one 14th century
Italian wit put it quote those who
engage engage in usury go to hell those
who fail to engage in usury fall into
poverty unquote one method by which the
church resolve this dilemma beginning in
the 12th century was to prevent was to
try to prevent the evil of Christian
usury by allowing Jews to engage in that
forbidden economic activity because Jews
were not subject to church law to the
prohibitions of canon law and they were
considered to be condemned in any case
the damnation because of their
repudiation of Christ and so in the
popular mind usury was not just a matter
of lending at interest it was a term of
opprobrium applied to any kind of
mercantile activity that was regarded as
unseemly and usury in turn was
identified with the Jews and with
Judaism within Western Christendom them
the image of Commerce
is closely connected to that of the Jew
who is regarded as an outsider as a
wanderer someone who is beyond the
community of shared faith and in
addition it was assumed that someone who
is so concerned about money must be
greedy or avaricious and this
identification of the characteristics of
capitalism that were considered unseemly
as Jewish would continue into the modern
period as you'll see now it's important
to understand that underlying this
condemnation of bunny lenders and often
of merchants was the assumption that
only people whose work produced sweat
really worked and produced most people
most peasants most laborers simply
couldn't imagine that production could
be increased by the decision to invest
resources in one place rather than
another or in one person rather than
another or in one commodity rather than
another the notion of trade and even
more the notion of money lending as
unproductive was often expressed in
images of parasitism the association of
money making with the Jews an
association that tended to taint
attitudes towards commerce among
Christians with survive in transmuted
form in the reflections of modern
intellectuals including some modern
intellectuals who are themselves of
Jewish lineage such as Karl Marx let me
turn briefly to the question then of
self-interest one of the most important
chapters in the interpretation of
capitalism concerns the changing of
value of the changing valuation of our
propensity zuv self-concern much of that
story involves a renaming of certain
character traits in such a way as to
change the moral evaluation of them the
founders of modern thought such as
Hobbes Bernard de Mandeville Voltaire
and Adam Smith took the Christian sins
of pride of greed and of avarice and
rican sieved and rechristened them as
self-interest Smith famously wrote in
The Wealth of Nations it is not
from the benevolence of the butcher the
brewer or the Baker that we expect our
dinner but from their regard to their
own interest by that he did not mean as
some romantics imagine that before the
rise of the market most lords and
peasants and artisans acted benevolently
towards one another and eschewed
self-interest Smith meant that the
market when it was properly structured
could channel self-interest in socially
positive ways incidentally the notion of
the potentially positive uses of
otherwise stigmatized passions was
somewhat familiar in the Jewish
tradition recall the Talmudic dictum
that quote were it not for the evil
inclination for the yetzer hara no one
would build a house marry a wife have
children or engage in business the the
insinuation of this of course is that
the evil inclination is Miss named the
evil inclination that it's only evil
when it's uncontrolled or when it's a
moderate indeed one can say with only a
touch of exaggeration that the discovery
of the potentially beneficial positive
uses of self-interest was the central
insight of the Enlightenment but it was
an insight that left many more lists
uncomfortable then and now think of
Rousseau think of the slogan people not
profits with the assumption that making
a profit is at odds with human
well-being or that human beings could
exist in a prosperous society without
profits that moralistic discomfort with
self-interest is evident in an early and
influential essay by Friedrich Engels
called toward a critique of political
economy angles chastised those who
engaged in trade writing when have you
been moral without being self-interested
without harboring at the back of your
mind in more immoral egoistical motives
so if angles first step was to go back
to pre Enlightenment understandings of
self-interest his second was to go back
to the Christian condemnation of usury
profits from trade angles reasoned in
this essay we're little different from
interest and could only be distinguished
from from interest by some logical by
some overly subtle logic chopping and
interest for angles was immoral as he
wrote the immorality of lending of at
interest of receiving without working
has long been recognized for what it is
by unprejudiced popular consciousness
which in such matters is usually right
but it was angles soon-to-be
collaborator Karl Marx who brought the
themes of the immorality of
self-interest and the unproductive
nature of money together and these
themes as you'll see was were central to
Marx's work from his early essay called
on the question of the Jews to his last
published work copy tall on the essay on
the question of the Jews which like
angles essay on the critique of
political economy was written in 1843
took up central charges made by
opponents of granting equal civil and
political rights to the Jews the Jews it
was said were unfit for civil rights
because they were egoistic and
materialistic Marx's answer was to agree
that the Jews were eager istic and
materialistic but then to go on that in
capitalist society everybody was
egoistic and materialistic here's how he
put it let us seek the secret of the
lettuce seek the secret of the Jew not
in his religion rather let us seek for
the secret of religion in the real Jew
what is the worldly basis of Judaism
practical need self-interest what is the
worldly cult of the Jew bargaining what
is his worldly God money well then the
self emancipation of our age would be
the emancipation from bargaining and
from money that is from practical real
judum here marks embraces all the
traditional negative stereotypes and
characterizations of the Jew but he does
so in order to stigmatize market
activity as such for Marx's strategy is
to endorse every
negative characterization of market
activity which Christians associated
with Jews but then to insist that those
qualities have now come to characterize
society as a whole very much including
Christians in other words for Marx do
bashing becomes a tool for bashing the
bourgeoisie marks also condemns the Jews
for their stubborn particularism now
thinkers like Voltaire and Adam Smith
often saw market activity as a way of
overcoming particularism because it
allows people of very differing ultimate
orientations and ultimate religious
commitments to cooperate with one
another Voltaire famously described the
London Stock Exchange where Jews
muhammadans and Christians trade with
one another and the Anglican takes the
promissory note of the quaker and so on
and his famous line and they call they
call infidel only the bankrupt remarks
by contrast capitalism represents the
universalization of particular interests
in a capitalist society Christians to
our egoistic and particular istic in the
socialist future as March imagined it as
Marx imagined it not only religious
difference would be overcome all self
interests individual and group was to be
eliminated Marx's moral critique of
capitalism drew on traditional
anti-jewish images not in order to
bolster anti-semitism but to blacken the
moral under the moral standing of
bourgeois capitalist society his essay
on the question of the Jews is therefore
a jana's faced read carefully Marx's
argument is clear enough all of the
negative moral evaluations which
traditional Christian and modern post
Christians applied to Jews should in
fact be applied to capitalist society
but because Marx himself reiterated so
many negative characterizations of the
Jews and their economic role with a
twist of the argument one could suggest
that the task was to rescue capitalism
from its unseen
jewish traits that was the theme with
variations of a number of subsequent
thinkers anti-jewish thinkers like
Ricard Vagner or very narrow zone Bart
down to the Nazi ideologist Alfred
Rosenberg now this link between
anti-semitism and Marx's anti-capitalism
went well beyond imagery and rhetoric if
Marx had one big idea it was that
capitalism was the rule of money that's
why he took a set of institutions that
Adam Smith had referred to as commercial
society or Hegel had referred to as
civil society and called them capitalism
the rule of capital and in Marx's labor
theory of value which forms the basis of
his book capital marks reformulated the
traditional prejudices against money
lending into a critique of the market in
the age of Industry take for example the
chapter of capital and called the
general formula of capital it has one
main point that capital is money that
makes money even if in a capitalist
society that occurs through the
intermediary stage of a merchant who
buys and sells commodities or the
industrialist who buys labor and uses it
to sell its products or in Marx's
resonant image quote the capitalist
knows that all commodities however
shabby they may look or bad they may
smell are in faith and in fact money
internally circumcised Jews and in
addition magical means by which to make
more money out of money unquote here
capital is not only identified with the
Jews marks in dow's money with the
Jewish stench which was attributed to
Jews in Christian Europe since medieval
times it's fundamental to the labor
theory of value that money is
unproductive only labour creates real
value and for marks that meant above all
the labor of the sweating industrial
workers in Marxist scheme the owners of
capital play no active role in economic
productivity just as the critics of
usury had always characterized money as
fundamentally unfair
ductive they're parasitic and marks
frequently describes the owners of
capital in capital as vampires growing
fat by sucking out the blood of the
workers who toil without sufficient
recompense so if one link between
anti-semitism and anti-capitalism is the
linkage of the market with the notion of
the unproductive and unearned game and
another is with the sins of greed and
avarice the third is the linkage between
Jews and entrepreneurial innovation
Joseph Schumpeter the 20th century
Austrian economist famously described
capitalism as a process of creative
destruction creative because it creates
new and more productive and hence more
profitable ways of doing things not only
new ways of making things but new ways
of organizing production and new ways of
distributing things and distributing
goods to new regions in which they've
never been distributed before that's the
creative part destructive because new
ways of producing organizing and
distributing commodities undermines the
viability of older means of production
it makes established ways of life
untenable and it does so in part by
introducing people to new commodities at
a price they can afford thus creating
new watts and in turn putting those
people who had satisfied old traditional
wats out of business in the process it
disrupts existing modes of production
existing social structures and the
cultures that went with them those who
introduced new methods of production
organization or distribution are the
people that schumpeter refers to as
entrepreneurs and the schumpeter pointed
out entrepreneurs are the dynamic
element of capitalism not as Marx
thought capital itself in other words
it's not the money it's what you do with
the money that matters and that depends
in no small part on the kind of people
handling the money and making this
visions about what to do with it Jews
have been disproportionately represented
among entrepreneurial innovators for
reasons that have less to do with
Judaism than to do with the position of
Jews in society people who are well
established who are well placed who are
well accepted into the elite have little
incentive to innovate precisely because
the Jews came from a commercial
subculture but because they were not
part of the established elite Jews often
ended up as entrepreneurial innovators
and this linkage of Jews with economic
innovation goes back at least to the
18th century but for conservatives such
economic innovation and the social and
cultural consequences that went with it
were often not a source of celebration
but of lament take the case of Adam
Smith's German contemporary useless
Moser in the late 18th century he was an
administrator in the tiny economic
backwater of osnabrück in western
Germany loser was an early critic of
what we have now come to call
globalization that is to say the spread
of international commerce to new regions
bringing with it new modes new types of
commodities and new modes of marketing
Newser condemned capitalism on the
grounds that had created new needs and
disrupted customary expectations and
thus unbalanced society judgments that
were common in the 18th century and that
have been revived by moralists
periodically since then he also railed
against the replacement of indigenous
tastes with new international tastes
tastes for goods produced abroad
Missouri reserved his greatest hostility
for the peddler the man who brought the
market economy to the countryside in the
primitive economy of rural osnabruck
most peasants had very limited contact
with the world market and the kinds of
goods that have made available in an
economically backward region like that
the main source of foreign goods were
peddlers that is people who literally
carried their stocks
on their backs and walked through the
byways of places like rule oz mabrook to
bring those products to the peasants in
their homes the peddler in other words
was a merchant with little capital and
no inherited status though the peasants
have little to spend and were hard to
reach to the peddler they represented an
untapped market and these peddlers were
often Jewish indeed they were Jewish not
only in 18th century osnabrück they were
often Jewish in other parts of Europe
and in the course of the 19th and even
20th century Jewish peddlers were often
to be found in North America in Latin
America and even in Africa they
represent them this entrepreneurial
function of introducing goods to new
markets where those Goods hadn't
appeared before to mizzer the activities
of the peddler ruined what he called the
good morals of the rural population by
awakening new needs and new desires once
said Newser the peasants had been
satisfied with indigenous products they
didn't aspire to these foreign goods
that were above their station it was the
peddler who led them astray by lead by
encouragement encouraging them to buy
items that they would never have thought
about on their own the peddler led
people to buy items that mousse or
thought that loser knew in his heart
they didn't really need and so he aimed
to protect the public from the from the
temptation of buying products that he
knew that they didn't really need what
were these pernicious but tempting goods
to which the peddler exposed unexpected
unsuspecting peasants and their wives
sil kirchoff's leather gloves wool
stockings metal buttons mirrors cotton
caps knives and needles the growing
taste for these novel and at the time
luxury items Moser claimed would destroy
the traditional economy and society of
osnabruck and he was right what he found
it hard to imagine was that the
disruption of existing ways of life
might be followed by something that was
not only different but in many respects
better the static protected Guild
economy of 18th century osnabruck
provided a reliable standard of living
for those people who were part of those
protected guilds it didn't do much for
the majority of the population that was
outside of them and it left very limited
opportunities even for those who were
inside of them but the fact that that
could be followed by something better
was something that lizard fart found it
hard to imagine the connection between
Jewish capitalists and the destruction
of indigenous culture was made most
directly by the man who actually
introduced the term capitalism into
mainstream social science namely very
nerds on bart born in 1863 zone bart was
among the most renowned social
scientists at the turn of the 20th
century and the term capitalism as a
noun came into academic social science
by way of his book modern capitalism
published in 1902 but over time zone
Bart concluded that capitalism meant the
decline of any culture worthy of the
name he became a cultural pessimist and
those most responsible for that decline
he thought were the Jews in zone Bart's
work then romantic anti-capitalist
communitarianism was linked to
anti-semitism son Bart portrayed the pre
capitalist economy of the artisan and
the peasant as natural and the modern
capitalist economy as artificial some
part zone Bart shared that romantic
prejudice that identified the archaic
with the authentic for zone Bart
capitalism's dissolution of the
traditional way of life of the German
folk was leading to what he called the
graveyard of culture while capitalism
might mark a quantitative gain it meant
he said a loss in the quality of life
robbing men of inner peace of their
relationship to nature and of the faith
of their fathers it led to overvaluing
the things of this world
capitalism according to zoom bar
destroyed the soul and led to the
standardization and massification of
cultural life this at a time when a
plethora of new cultural commodities
were becoming available to most of the
German public incidentally son Bart
linked capitalism with the Jews the
Jewish mind he said was characterized by
egoism self-interest and abstraction
precisely the qualities most suited for
capitalism and his key witness for the
elective affinity between capitalism and
the Jewish character was none other than
Karl Marx whose essay on the question of
the Jews zomb art quoted with approval
zomb arts identification of the Jews
with the elements of capitalism that he
most feared provide provided a scholarly
patina for what was already one of the
most frequent motifs of anti-semites not
only in Germany but also in Britain and
turn of the century France the Jews they
claimed were responsible for everything
bad about capitalism and the modern
world let me turn then to the question
the anti-capitalist theme of the
resentment of success it was Joseph
Schumpeter again who pointed to another
effect of entrepreneurial creative
destruction it led to what Nietzsche had
called raised on to MA the attempt of
the resentful majority to devalue the
achievements of the creative and of the
successful for some people the process
the capitalist process of creative
destruction brought real economic
decline even the best maker of buggy
whips for example was wiped out by the
coming of the automobile for many others
capitalist competition and creativity
brought about some economic gain but
relative decline especially those people
who are part of old or established
elites found there a leak position
transformed or displaced by new elites
who arose from new waves of capitalist
creativity and those elites often
responded by scorning the newly
successful as par
the news as upstarts without the
respectability of old money schumpeter
didn't explore the role of the Jews in
all this but his younger V is younger
contemporary in Vienna friedrich hayek
did writing in the 1930s and 1940s in
the age of national socialism Hayek
pointed to a phenomenon that acute
European observers could hardly fail to
notice though they differed as to its
significance and that was that once
granted equality of civil rights in
civic opportunity the Jewish minority in
Eastern and Central Europe often
outperformed the ethno-religious
majority the reasons for that were not
so hard to discover or to understand the
Jews for centuries had been part of a
commercial subculture and so with the
rise of new commercial opportunities
they did disproportionately well in a
society in which entry into the free
professions was based upon educational
achievement the Jews culture of the book
stood them in good stead and as a
minority long excluded from the
established positions of political and
economic power the Jews were especially
attuned to finding novel ways to make
use of existing resources to spot
economic opportunities in other words
Jews were the classic case of what we
sometimes call a merchant minority and
as analysts from friedrich hayek through
ernest Gellner through a Meech wah have
noted in periods of capitalists take off
such minorities do especially well the
result is often movements that seek to
exclude or extrude those merchant
minorities on the grounds that the act
that the dominant ethnic group is
entitled to economic supremacy Hayek
knew of what he spoke Hayek was a
liberal great believer in in individual
rights in limited government and in the
capitalist market and his liberalism was
influenced by his close contact with
Jews in interwar Vienna at a time when
many others of his class including
members of his own
family and is leading academic teachers
favorite attempts to exclude people of
Jewish origin from economic cultural and
political life for Hayek Jews were
prototypical of the type of person whose
talents led to economic progress but
whose success was resented by the mass
of the population there was therefore a
close link Hayek said it between
anti-capitalism and anti-semitism in his
book the Road to Serfdom of 1944 he
noted that in Germany and Austria the
Jew had come to be regarded as
representative of capitalism quote it's
the old story he wrote of the alien race
being admitted only to the less
respected trades and then being hated
still more for practicing them the fact
that German anti-semitism and at the
capitalism spring from the same root is
of great importance for understanding
what has happened there but this is
rarely grasped by foreign observers he
wrote in fact Hayek regarded fascism and
Nazism as desperate attempts by social
losers in the process of capitalist
development to regain the rewards denied
them in the marketplace through force
and through ideological special pleading
the competitive market as Hayek went on
to explain in his later work created new
knowledge about the potential uses of
resources capitalism as Hayek understood
it was fundamentally dynamic and that
dinette that dynamism was due to the
discovery of new needs and new ways of
fulfilling them by entrepreneurs
possessed with the quality that he
called resourcefulness that economic
vibrancy created social created a social
and cultural dynamic it demanded the
adaptation of old ways of thinking and
behaving it was the dynamic and
resourceful few who forced the less
resourceful many to adapt to rationalize
their behavior by imitating that of the
more successful and this process is
Hayek realized was sometimes painful and
it was bound to be resented by those who
prefer to run in the
grooves of established ways of life for
Hayek then the Jews were merely the most
striking example of those whose
resourcefulness led to the creative
destruction so characteristic of
competitive capitalism for all these
reasons then in the modern West
anti-semitism has often been a way of
expressing discontent with capitalist
modernity some disliked it for
destroying traditional modes of life and
altering traditional cultures especially
when their own social and cultural
status was challenged by the new
capitalist modes and orders others have
never come to terms with the notion that
the pursuit of self-interest can lead to
beneficial social outcomes they longed
for a kind of fraternal community where
all were brothers or sisters and no one
sought to profit from his relations with
others in general acceptance of the
market both popular and intellectual
seems to go hand in hand with a decline
of anti-semitism the renewed spread of
capitalist markets across borders in
recent decades has been of benefit to
millions of people across the globe
indeed hundreds of millions of people
above all in China and in India but it
has also unsettled existing ways of
doing things and under the rubric of
anti-globalization it has renewed the
recurrent lament about the destructive
influence of the market the fear of
economic change and resentment of those
more successful in the process of
capitalist innovation has by no means
disappeared blaming the lenders of money
for the failures of the corrupt and the
inept is a recurrent contemporary theme
though the object of AA block we is now
focused on the International Monetary
Fund or the World Bank can the
continuing spread of capitalism has
opened up new cultural possibilities for
those of us in the West and beyond the
West indeed every day it's changing they
already fluid boundaries of the West as
in the past it's open it opens up
new possibilities to some exposing them
to new ways of consumption and
production and new ways of imagining
themselves these processes have real
advantages and potential dangers they'll
continue to be viewed as threats by
those who seek to maintain the existing
ways of production consumption and
imagination given the history that I've
recounted all too briefly today
anti-semitism will no doubt continue to
be one of the foremost idioms in which
anti-capitalism finds expression thank
you and we have time for we have lots of
time for questions the people from
c-span have told me to tell you that if
you have a question you should speak
into their mic which will not amplify
your voice but which will make it
accessible to the c-span audience
informative
let me ask you I think it's one question
with two parts but it could be it could
be two questions and what the first
would do for one's better the first part
of it is to if you could if you could
explain to us a little bit more about
the linkage that is you've often put it
in the Bleck sure between ant between
the two parts of your theme
anti-capitalism and anti so in
anti-semitism in other words is there
simply a kind of loose affinity between
the two or do you see one driving the
other is anti-capitalism the source of
anti-semitism or do you see more likely
it to be the reverse that anti-semitism
is what really drives anti-capitalism so
I'd like to know in the first place a
little bit about how you understand that
linkage and secondly would you I mean
has your research tended to confirm that
where you find either anti-capitalism or
anti-semitism you tend to find the other
in other words do these two invariably
you focused on instances where these go
together is that invariably the case or
to use the language of my colleagues and
social and social sciences do you see
these justice is independent variables
that will sometimes go together but not
necessarily so ah the answer is i think
that i do not i don't see them as
necessarily going together there are
certain case there are certainly cases
in modern Europe and all across the
globe of anti-capitalism that is
unaffected by uninfluenced by
anti-semitism and there are cases rarer
of anti-semitism that is unlinked 22
anti-capitalism I wouldn't call them
independent variables either though
they're they're linked variables and
that is in part because as I've tried to
explain there's a plethora of images
metaphors
concepts and associations for thinking
about fundamental aspects of a
capitalist economy above all merchant
activity and the related activity of
lending money which is integrally
related to merchant activity and that
that fund of images and metaphors and
negative connotations acts as a kind of
filter through which people who have
those filters in their mind understand
the empirical phenomena that they see in
front of them in other words it tends to
taint their interpretation of those
processes and as I say the fact that
these negative connotations were linked
with a traditionally stigmatized
minority who were allowed to engage in
such occupations precisely because they
were seen as beyond salvation means that
this set of images tends to taint the
way or in many times and places that
people have thought about merchant
activity that they thought about
capitalism and on the other hand it
provides a kind of it provides a kind of
rhetorical wellspring by which to
stigmatize capitalist activity as such
even when the motivation isn't itself
anti-semitic as it wasn't for example in
the case of marks and there's one other
variation and that is to stigmatize
those elements of the kind of case of
projection in other where people who do
engage in this kind of activity and feel
guilty about it project the negative
elements of it upon the Jews so I think
in short these anti-semitism and
anti-capitalism certainly exist
independent of one another but in fact
they are often interlinked both causally
and and in other ways and one of course
one of the odd and striking facts of
more a very recent history is the the
migration of some of these images to
the Islamic world just as usury was
forbidden in Christianity it's also of
course forbidden in Islam and of course
like any commercial culture once that
culture develops you develop various
kinds of legal fictions for so that you
can actually have borrowing landing of
money but the negative stigmatization of
usury remains and when one listens to
some of the tapes of Osama bin Laden you
have this linkage of Jews and usury
again in a part of the world where that
was not particularly familiar linkage so
I can't figure out Stephen all the
directions of causality but those are
some Jews playing a disproportionate
rowlands the African slave trade and how
does that relate to this it's another
case of taking one of the most
stigmatized elements of capitalist
activity and in this case legitimately
stigmatized I think in projecting it
upon the Jews but this is a topic on
Willa on which I will not say another
word because David Brian Davis is here
and he's written one of the most
excellent studies of this topic and so
of others so there's a wide scholarship
on it and I think it's just a recurrent
case as I say of taking a stigmatized
part of capitalism and associating with
in this case with very little empirical
legitimacy with the juice a little bit
more this issue of projecting the at the
unpleasant aspects of capitalism onto
the Jews of people who are engaging in
themselves clearly anti-semitism and
anti-capitalism have a long long long
history but something changes in the
late nineteenth in the nineteenth and
twentieth century which is that the
traditional governing elite
the aristocratic structure collapses so
that the people who are now running the
nations of Europe are the people who
previously were being stigmatized as
parva news and and vulgar and
money-grubbing and so forth most cases
not Jews in fact in almost all cases not
Jews it strikes me as interesting that
that the the nineteenth and twentieth
century stereotypes of Jews looks so
much like the eighteenth seventeenth and
eighteenth century stereotypes of the
bourgeoisie by the aristocracy there's
the theological dimension is largely
missing and and and this in this
economic dimension has become central
could you say something about about that
and maybe tie it to the the problem of a
new ruling class a new ruling group that
have stepped into the shoes of a group
that for years condemned them okay I
will but before I say something about
that let me say something about this
projection of of character qualities
that can occur and are particularly
likely to occur in a market economy onto
the Jews one of the people who did that
somewhat to my surprise it was at least
I was quite surprised by how significant
this was in his thought was Voltaire
who's very striking not only because he
almost single-handedly creates the
modern role of the intellectual but he
somebody who himself was involved in
very wide range of financial activity
including money lending lending money to
royalty in return for annuities trading
in a number of transnational
corporations at the time and we know
from some of those around him that he
often did so in a ravish in a very shady
fashion and indeed as Madame the knee
his longtime mistress said your heart is
pierced by avarice but we tried
keep this hidden well Voltaire responded
by attributing these notions of avarice
and so on precisely to the Jews and he
did so not just not only when he had
contact with Jews but before he had
contact with Jews and in his writings
they occur in an almost a racial sense
that is he he he uses cases cases from
the Bible to project these qualities
back upon Abraham and the patriarchs and
so on so it precedes the late nineteenth
and early twentieth century it's true
that in the late nineteenth and early
twentieth century well first of all the
aristocracy doesn't lose power as
quickly as you might think and some of
them maintain power because they engage
or have relations with new forms of
capitalist activity but it's striking
that one of the one of the major groups
leadership groups behind anti-semitic
movements in say Hungary in the 1890s is
precisely the declining gentry that is
those landowners who are going downhill
because their their economic mode is
really on the decline and they actually
become leaders of the anti-semitic
movement there and you have some similar
cases in Germany it's most striking in
the case of Hungary and yes it's true
that the the you have this interlinking
of criticisms of the Jew and criticisms
of the bourgeois and that begins fairly
early and as you've indicated picks up
picks up steam over time curious I do um
do Jews other writings of Jews about
themselves in their role in their
economic role in Europe not marks and so
forth but earlier earlier writings and
maybe even more modern writings but not
the sort of self-hating type a vision
that Marx presents but a more positive
attitude towards themselves
as the creators of economy and wealth in
in the in the places in which they
happen to live sure there are and it
goes through lots of stages one of the
earliest defenders of various forms of
international commerce and of government
debt is actually an 18th century Jewish
intellectual by name of Isaac dipinto
who corresponded with Voltaire about
these matters and about many other
matters as well Derek penslar has
written a wonderful book called
Shylock's grandchildren that deals with
Jewish self-reflection on these issues
suffice it to say that there are times
when when on the one hand there were
times when Jews proudly called attention
to their role as capitalist innovators
and their contributions to capitalist
society and there are other times in
which they internalized the criticisms
of mercantile life and commerce that
came from outside one of the great
ironies of history is that in the late
nineteenth and early twentieth century
socialism astern alized some of these
negative views of mercantile activity
and try to turn the Jews back into a
nation of of agriculturalists and manual
workers at a time when that was becoming
that was falling ever behind the cutting
edge of capitalist modernity so yes
there's a long history of Jewish
reflection on this some of it as I say
internalizing these auntie's
anti-capitalist views and some of it
pointing to the role of Jews in
capitalist activity in a positive way
and some of the some of what some Jewish
thinkers have even seen as affinities
between Judaism and capitalism of rabbi
sacks the chief rabbi of Great Britain
has written along these lines so on yes
for the world to have a different
tradition like China and Japan or
arriving at this kind of thinking what
are they have they see this uh I'm not
sure I I mean I have some sensitive but
I'm really not sure I know that so that
recently so far the might my book is
there are three contracts to translate
it there into Chinese Japanese and
Korean so I guess people there are
interested in these issues there's no
doubt that that these anti-semitic
images play a much diminished role in
those parts of the world on the other
hand they still do play some role which
is quite remarkable given that there are
essentially no Jews in those societies
but it's an area in which I'm not really
that knowledgeable as you're speaking I
was wondering whether you found anything
particularly unique about the American
experience of this link between
capitalism and anti-semitism both
because America's traditionally been
such a hotbed of of capitalism the world
and also because so many other ethnic
groups in America have been associated
with with business and in commerce and
entrepreneurial sorts of activities uh
well my book deals only tangentially
with the United States my focus is on
Europe but I do deal with a number of
thinkers who came to the United States
in the 20th century and hence wrote
about the American experience like
Schumpeter or Herbert marcuzzo or Hayek
all of whom wrote substantial works were
there when they were in the United
States the answer is that these linkages
do exist in American history they're
certainly diminished by the fact that
America has long been a society with a
greater versed of all with a greater
variety of immigrant groups and so the
although it has been possible at very
is times to distinguish the ethno
national majority from various
minorities it's been it's been harder
though there's been repeated attempts to
do so it's also because America really
was founded on a much more philo
capitalist foundation than than any
previous country I mean certainly the
promotion of Commerce was very much on
the minds of say the authors of the
Federalist Papers and so in that sense
you had less suspicion of Commerce and
in that sense a lesser propensity to
anti-semitism which doesn't mean that it
didn't exist in precisely these forms
you had some elements of it in
turn-of-the-century populism just as you
did in incomparable movements in Germany
and Eastern Europe and so on the best
case of capitalist projection of images
that i know of course is the case of
henry ford who as you know as you may
know in the 1920s funded the mass
distribution of the protocols of the
Elders of Zion a fabrication intending
to show that Jews were trying to take
over the world through capitalism and
socialism Ford who was one of the great
Paragons of American entrepreneurial
capitalism and innovation took all the
negative stereotypes about the effects
of capitalism and made the Jews their
cause in the 1930s a a number of
demagogues including the Catholic priest
the father Coughlin in the Detroit area
place the great deal of emphasis on this
link on the evils of bankers and their
connections with the Jews so one
certainly finds these things in American
history thank God they play a more
subordinate role than they have in in
the histories of other nations
if you could talk a bit more about the
links between Philo semitism which
sometimes involves elements of
anti-semitism and Philo capitalism which
is something that exists even in places
where there aren't really Jews like
Japan it's true that on the whole
liberals in the sense of those who
againt in the European sense of those
who favor market activity do tend to be
non anti-semitic and indeed often anti
anti Semitic that I think is the most um
significant link whether there is a link
to something stronger a kind of pro
Jewish attitude Philo semitism in that
sense and Philo capitalism the answer is
probably yes but it primarily takes the
form of anti anti-semitism as far as
I've been able to see
other other questions yes rabbi open it
you may to the the rabbinic this is a
rabbi question i guess the rabbinic
understanding of the evil inclination
and suggested that a proper reading of
the rabbis would lead to the conclusion
that it really isn't evil unless it's
exercised in temperately that's say and
so i'm wondering if there are other
elements inside of rabbinic judaism that
strike you is making Judaism as we know
it today particularly compatible with
capitalist culture or whether the
religion in your judgment is perhaps
neutral as a as a factor in Jewish
engagement in capitalism it is a factor
to some degree but not when taken to an
extreme let me explain let me explain
what I mean it's true that I mean you
know better than I do about this but
it's true that there's no antipathy to
material life as such in Judaism there's
no negation of the world in its material
sense in Judaism there is an emphasis as
you know I'm sure better than I do in
the Talmud on the importance of making a
living as an honorable thing to do and
the importance of raising a family which
requires making a living as an honorable
and important thing to do that was less
true in cultures in which the
intellectual elite was celibate by
definition and prided itself on such as
such so there are some affinities in
that sense on the other hand you can
take things to an extreme it's
interesting when you look at the
ultra-orthodox population in a place
like Israel where they've managed to get
themselves funded essentially by the
state so that they don't have to make a
living to some degree their wives make a
living additionally but you know there
there is there is of course a tension
between the Jewish emphasis upon study
and making a living that's a theme of
one of the great
Jewish novels of yeshiva bye bye hi I'm
grata and so that tension is there but I
think it's true that one doesn't have
the kind of antipathy to material life
that one has in some strains of
Christianity that do lead to a kind of
potentially at least elective affinity
between Jews and economic activity I
think that's the most I can say about it
yes oh well that's this fellow has the
first question then we'll come back to
you question that you should feel free
to ignore because it's slightly off the
topic of anti-semitism I was always
reading the jacket to your book in the
room before the lecture and I noticed
that you talked about attitudes towards
Commerce and capitalism in classical
Greece and Rome yeah as part of your
book and I always kind of associated
capitalism as limit came out of the
Enlightenment and came out of Adam Smith
and so if you could offer maybe two or
three comments about you know one in
your book deals with antiquity in
capitalism mm-hm or ignore it well I'll
just be I'll just be very brief about it
you know when you look at the great
classical philosophers they tended to I
mean Plato above all and Aristotle they
tended to see people that group of
people who produce as a lesser group of
people in terms of their moral and
political value and they didn't want
them to be part of the rulership of the
state and that set of associations
between that conflict that say between
or perceived conflict between economic
productivity and political activity
remained in what we've come to call the
Civic Republican tradition from its
ancient sources through some elements of
its modern reformulations in the in the
early modern period so there's some
there's some continuity that way as I
said Adam Smith didn't create capitalism
Adam Smith looked at a set of
institutions of market institutions that
were already around him that were
transforming life in ways that he
thought were in many ways positive or at
least potentially positive and he
suggested ways of thinking about that
those institutions as a system and ways
of reforming them so that they would be
of greater benefit to more people but
it's true that there's a very close link
between the praise of capitalist
activity and the Enlightenment which
doesn't mean that there weren't internal
critics of that in the Enlightenment of
which Rousseau is merely the best known
but it's
isn't it odd that for in at university
campuses the term enlightenment gets
thrown around a lot when it's thrilled
around a lot thrown around in a positive
sense the importance of the market and
capitalist activity to the enlightenment
is rarely highlighted and sometimes not
even mentioned sorry ties to my question
which is seems to me that there are kind
of two motivations for for
anti-capitalism a kind of maybe a
popular anti-capitalism might be a
unhappiness with the distribution of
goods and not a sense that the market or
that a that an expansion of economic
activity as a whole is ipso facto a bad
thing and then another one that goes to
what you were talking about this sort of
discomfort of Christian society and
especially theologically with the world
which is not supposed to be around for
very long in the earliest formulations
of Christianity so that it's the idea
that of economic expansion and an
improved standard of living is not
necessarily an unmitigated good it's
kind of a bad thing in and of itself we
should be living a simpler life in the
Garden of Eden but it seems to me that
these are two very different problems
very different questions and have you
seen this as this emerged at all in your
research sort of two different basis for
opposition to capitalism well as I say
there's a difference between opposition
to capitalism and wanting to alter or
reform the distribution of goods in one
or another capitalist society that
desire to
alter the distribution somewhat well
leaving the fundamental institutions in
place is not as I say in an
anti-capitalist one one thinks of
someone like Cannes who though actually
in some of his less economic writings
did have some anti-capitalist sentiments
and propensity that I that I deal with
in the book but still on the whole was
in favor of making the thing work better
with a somewhat changed distribution and
it's it's true that those people the
question of capitalism and worldliness
is an ongoing one I mean one of the
things that the great thinkers the great
proto Enlightenment thinkers I'm
thinking above all of Hobbes and Spinoza
wanted to do was to make worldly life
more pleasant not only more pleasant in
the sense of our material well-being but
expanding the range of things that we
could think about and the intellectual
pleasures and including among material
pleasures the pleasure of peace and part
of doing that was to make men less
focused on their everlasting salvation
on the grounds if on the grounds that
that an emphasis on their everlasting
salvation would lead them to oppress
others who did not share their views of
everlasting transfer of everlasting
salvation and so diffusing those
sentiments was part of what Hobbes
wanted to do in order to bring about a
society more focused on worldly
well-being and that has always been a
source of concern and discomfort for
those who think of salvation primarily
in the afterlife and it still is today
I'm very pleased that at the very end of
the answer to the last question excuse
me the name of Spinoza was mentioned
because it would be hard for me to
imagine a lecturer talk dealing with the
general betterment and improvement of
humanity without at least some nod in in
that direction but I want to want to
thank you all for coming today and I
particularly want to thank our lecturer
Jerry Muller for sharing his ideas and
his new book with us and for those of
you who want more it is unsalable
Jerry Muller is a history professor at
Catholic University of America the mind
in the market is published by Konami a
division of Random House visit Random
House calm / can opt for more
information